claudio roldan has owned this hardware
store in buenos aires for 11 years
he says he's struggling to keep it open
as inflation source
i have been working since i was 14 years
old and of course i want change but i
don't think it's going to happen
people ask me why i keep this shop open
but what am i going to do i have to pay
rent electricity i cannot afford to
close down
argentina has one of the highest
inflation rates in the world
with an average close to six percent a
month
even though the exchange rate is
controlled by the government and ongoing
financial crisis means the price of the
local currency at the unofficial
exchange rate drops on an hourly basis
this is the argentine peso and what
people are seeing is that it's losing
value every minute about two weeks ago
you needed around twenty thousand pesos
to buy one hundred dollars now you need
over 30 000 to buy the same amount of
dollars the problem is that this
translates into more inflation and more
instability
the government provides assistance to
millions of poor people but in recent
months social movements that represent
informal workers have been demanding a
universal basic wage
there is a presence of the state but all
of that has been taken away by inflation
and now we need to help the people until
a few years ago that money allowed you
to be above the poverty line now half
the population lives in poverty
since taking office president alberto
fernandez has closed a 40 billion dollar
agreement with international monetary
fund and promised to jump-start the
economy but mounting economic problems
and deep divisions with his powerful
vice president christina fernandez the
kirchner have paralyzed his
administration
analysts say the government is facing a
confidence crisis yeah i think it's a
statement that leads to a lack of
confidence so no one expect expects um
things to change let me give you an
example as i told you before in
argentina energy prices are subsidized
that's a big destruction of the economy
since the beginning of the alberta
france's government the growing ministry
has been trying to sort of cut those
those subsidies that actually are
pro-rich but the kishner faction within
the government has been blocking that
for two years that's a a an example of
the level of paralysis
that permits every level of the
government and that's
that obviously creates uncertainty among
people
argentina is rich in natural resources
and has the capacity to feed millions of
people not only within its borders but
also around the world
but it's stuck in a seemingly endless
cycle of economic troubles that several
administrations have been unable to
resolve
teresa al jazeera buenos aires